♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute and I'll show you
how Dataflow can help you process
and enrich data at scale.
Data is generated in real time
from different sources
but capturing, processing,
and analyzing it is not easy
because it's usually not
in the desired format
for your downstream systems.
Solution? Dataflow.
Dataflow is a serverless,
fast, and cost-effective
data-processing service
for stream and batch data
which removes operational
overhead by automating
the infrastructure provisioning,
and auto-scaling as your data grows.
Using Dataflow is easy.
You read the data from the source,
transform it, and write it
back into a sink.
It provides portability with
the processing pipeline created
using open source Apache Beam libraries
in the language of your choice
and applying it as Dataflow job
which then executes the processing
on worker virtual machines.
You can create and run Dataflow jobs
using the Cloud Console UI,
gCloud CLI, or the APIs.
You can use prebuilt or custom templates,
or write SQL statements
to develop pipelines
right from BigQuery UI
or use AI Platform Notebooks.
Security is taken care of
with all the data encrypted
at rest and in transit
with an option to use
customer-managed encryption keys.
Additionally you can use private IPs
and VPC service controls
to secure the environment.
For all these reasons
Dataflow is a great choice
for use cases such as real-time AI,
data warehousing or stream analytics.
So, next time you're looking
to processing and enrich any data,
take a minute to look at Dataflow.
To learn more, check out:
cloud.google.com/Dataflow